what's the difference between the brown
eggs and the white eggs the yellow the
white they think they're better than the
brown ones i'm pretty sure they're
always getting arrested yeah but the
broccoli
they come home cracked
they're like what's wrong back here oh
they're [__] dude hit me
grab the chips
i had a joke here's a joke that i wrote
that you know you know latinos i always
listen to other people when they order
they go huh can we get three egg white
omelets
and then can we get like veggies on the
side and dude's listening
yeah
and the waiter passes by and he goes hey
can we have the yellows
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg hi oh my god
smoking the green doesn't have to be
mean for the smoothest and coldest
cannabis smoking experience you gotta
check out freeze pipe freeze pipe makes
a unique line of freezable pipes
bubblers bongs and more for a chilly
smoking experience you gotta feel to
believe okay ever since whoever first
found that weed
that there was a lot of things out there
cilantro there was you know nutmeg
and everything but
whoever found the actual marijuana plant
and said hey man let's burn this to stay
warm
and then
they realized you could get high from it
from that day to the freeze pipe there's
a lot of ways to smoke uh uh the green
but i'm gonna tell you the freeze pipe
is the best way because it's almost like
air conditioned weed
like you get it it's colder it opens
europe i'm sure it opens up your area
and then you get it and
i don't think
that there's been an invention
in marijuana
that
is as good as this that that it cools it
down people get that you burn that stuff
in your throat or whatever but this is
the stuff you have to look out for
when it's so smooth going in and then
the way home
all right
shop the entire collection of the
freezepipe.com use the code omghi
for 10 off and find everything from
freezable pipes to bubblers bongs
at the freeze freezepipe.com list
everybody
have somebody if you don't all believe
in it have somebody buy one and pass it
around it will change the way that you
look at marijuana forever
and guilt too make sure you use the code
omg
for 10 of your entire order
this is uh you know how ice melts in the
drink and you're like oh my drink i
watered down imagine being able to smoke
weed with the cool breeze coming through
almost like when you put gold bun on
your werewolves
has anybody started crying and they're
drunk
no
no started crying when you're drinking
maybe me
cry but i'm not drunk
you just cry yeah every once in a while
you know do you cry when you get
somebody he says something but not when
i'm drunk i never cried when i'm drunk
if anything all i ever do is laugh more
not me sagittarius okay
is that part of that is that part of his
sign that he don't cry actually oh no i
mean actually
i'm a feces but my friends call me
number two
oh my gosh that's a good kill can you
believe that that night sucker let this
bother catch him
[Laughter]
he probably wasn't a jail cell ching out
them that's right some dude that
couldn't stop laughing captured me
and he never cries when he's drunk
we laughed
are there any of those guys still out
there anymore now with social media like
there's no
suspense anymore huh no
like you know
what we're talking we talk about the
nightstalker all the time but you know
you you weren't born yet but in the 80s
when that dude was out there
when it started to get dark you could
feel in the city
like danger like i got to get my ass
from everybody
and even though he had already you know
had been
killing people everywhere
he hit in northridge i worked at
northridge and you could feel and
everybody's just going home man
and he would strike even when people
were expecting him to strike he still
did it
that's a lot they know their white dudes
are right
they're going to catch them
[__] that man i said what about dogs i
said what deter you from going into a
house
and he says i said dogs he said no no i
got along with dogs
i can have dogs
well then what made you stay away from
some houses
and he says an alarm system he says if
they had a good alarm system i'd stay
away well what constitutes a good alarm
so well if they had a sign out in front
you know that was part of it you know
you'd see there you go there's already
caution
that's what everybody would say you know
if somebody was getting adt or whatever
they had back then
and the truck was across the street
you'd walk over and the guy would come
out there working hey man uh
my grandma want to ask do you guys
have any stickers or anything that you
guys sell
or a sign or anything and they'd be like
no you got to do the thing and then in
the middle of the night you go george go
get that sign on the street and bring it
back
you know they had it i want to say it
was adt one of the big security
companies maybe brinks
one of the two they had a fundraiser for
the sheriff and he was there and we're
just talking this is the president of
the company and he tells me
he said you know what i like he says i'm
going to give you the best burglar alarm
system we have
believe today i'm going to give you one
let me put on it i hit that white lady
in the front no he says here it is he
says he was more determined it was a it
was a sign it was a lawn sign stick this
in your yard he says
it'll keep more burglars away from your
house than anything you've ever imagined
do you know what you know do you want me
to tell you what the best
better than a night stick
better than that thing we talked about
the sap with the lead in it the leather
a picture of my swagger
that one
the the best thing
for to keep in your car around your
house
at dodger stadium they would sell a
dodger bat that was about that long
and it was blue yeah and it was a
miniature dodger bat yeah you had one of
those and you could grab it like that
and somebody would grab you and grab
that little bat bam
that hurts
the cops pulled you over it just looked
like your kid left his bat in the car
yeah hey
it was extra innings
you know full-sized bat yeah that [__]
was yeah you hit somebody with one of
those
yeah okay so
can you introduce a guest uh yeah
joining us on the podcast today is
rapper snow the product and entertainer
fellow podcaster as well oh oh yeah a
little bit
tell me about that cassie um basically
it started with um my girlfriend and i
were just at home kovit was happening i
didn't you know tour i didn't have any
shows or anything and i was just like
you know go downstairs cheese me out a
little bit on the mics and um we already
filmed and have a vlog channel and stuff
so
it was cool it's a cool way to uh stay
connected with the fans you know so so
are you different are you different when
you do your podcast than when you are on
stage or when people see you in public i
think so that's why i started the
channel like it's called everyday days
because those are like my everyday days
you know like i'm snow the product or
whatever you know like a product yes
it's in the name um but then on those
days
like no makeup like hair all messed up
you know drunk
serious yeah why not you know that's
what we do so yeah you grabbed your
beard sometimes people try to like you
know put the best uh image forward you
know
yeah but but but the one thing about
podcasts is that
you can be more real or you should be
more real here because if you're not you
can't be real doing this like for me
when people listen to this they'll say
like you know they see you in your show
but that's all kind of scripted and they
see you doing stand up that's kind of
like that but no one's ever seen me
yeah like this for the because of you a
little more
people have you know what is it like
it's like four friends getting together
sitting around having a beer and just
shooting the [__] around having a beer
that that's what's up
no yeah exactly
that's what that's that's why i thought
it was cool you know i live with a few
of my cousins my brother you know we
live on a ranch and we just kind of
shoot the [__] get drunk drink tequila
you know talk about whatever everything
from like
lgbt to politics to just growing up
hispanic too and i just can't imagine
you looking
that much different you have natural
beauty skins your skin right now you
have natural beauty so you get on there
without makeup
you know no i mean you know there's
there's hate comments for sure you know
you gotta live nowadays with with
everybody having an opinion but um
as i was saying before you know i grew
up really like
my deals are really tough and they were
really hard on on us you know which kind
of created a lot of the
shyness and like weirdness or whatever
which is kind of what i'm working
through i mean that's kind of what my
whole identity is right whether it's
from music or podcast it's just me
talking about getting over whatever the
hell i got when i was little
do you think that do you think that um
um
rappers are born or can they be i guess
they could be created but but i think
that you have to
you know as a detective or as a producer
or somebody in public there's a certain
amount of
of like weight you have to carry
to make somebody more creative or
different yeah you know everybody's
different but a lot of people don't want
to go down the road where they talk
about
what their childhood was or what their
situation was
because first of all
it um
like it especially now everybody
comments on it but when i would i think
it's fuel that you take to try to get
you to the next place and if you ignore
it then you're ignoring your life and
really the best rappers that and and
best people actors
that you that you get are the ones that
take their life and
yeah yeah exactly i mean you have a
particular angle
with exactly how you were razor exactly
how you live so if you try to do
whatever's popular by the time that you
catch that you already missed the train
like that already exists you know so
yeah i
i definitely figured out a while back
that like there's only there's only one
me it's a very particular situation to
be in and i like it that's right i think
that if you say you know there's only
one person like that or to create
somebody because um
you know in
in in in coming up like i never saw any
any chicano comedians really when i was
a kid that was you know richard pryor
freddie prince that killed himself there
wasn't any really and then you kind of
focus on hey you know i'd like to try to
be a comedian it wasn't i mean it's not
easy
anything good is not easy but but
in seeing you and watching your videos
like i can remember especially being
older that
you have created
a place for yourself that did not exist
before yeah and i mean those are the
people that really
have no comparison you'll say oh
doug or the guy on the road said oh he's
like a black uh andy griffin
[Laughter]
so like dude you know they don't even
know what they're saying
and in watching you and watching the way
you rap it it in the both languages and
the words
and in the in the film failure
familiarity of familiarity of those
words
and uh that you don't you wouldn't hear
them in a rap song in english and in
spanish like that to me
is you're taking a lot of ingredients
now where
an actor or a rapper can be of one kind
she's
got three different things going on in
the same song
that's that that's like flabbergasted
right now i can't believe it that's deep
man that's deep that's deep because when
you know when you when my comedy came
out they would say oh man but your
grandmother reminds me of my grandmother
uh did grandma carry a 2200 person no
all right then
uh and in the tv show my mom in the
beginning always talked about having a
gun in her purse and she did but the
actors had we had a gun in her purse my
grandmother had a 22 mm-hmm in her purse
and then she said good job go get my gun
i took it out i had makeup on it
powder from her makeup like oh things
not going to shoot had like a candy in
there and uh
and powder like about a little gun my
[__]
face makeup came out but but she did she
i don't know why she carried it like she
never got robbed in that bad
neighborhood but she would be like we
should look and she goes so i'll be
right back
she's gonna get her gun your
grandmother's gonna get my gun let's go
but but but in those things like
because selena selena
you know uh uh was not uh um
as big
uh before and she sang that that way for
that time and so i'm like that's all
right for that time but in this time it
would be considered slow
yeah you know you're not slow like
you're in this in this time you're fast
you you know you know you understand
social media how you almost have to
appear to be in two places at the same
time listening to you rap the way you do
is fast there ain't no way i can talk
that fast number one
articulate the way you do and enunciate
and but it makes it makes sense
it's a story you're telling and i can
follow it ain't no way i could ever
repeat it but i can follow it
by the way i really am caught off guard
because i didn't like i thought i was
gonna like introduce myself and like
talk and then like to be like told that
y'all actually listen to myself that's
like really cool it's an honor to be
honest okay so can you give an ass oh
yeah let me drink beer once you get to
the bottom of that one you'll be like
they told me
[Laughter]
so walk me through the the whole uh
thing of
like
how did you hear where where did you
hear the music how did you hear the
music how did you decide to put
the all that stuff together though i
mean dude it's not easy is it no it's
not it's not i
my dad
really like my dad he hated it you know
he's a very stereotypical macho mexican
dude you know he did not believe in
in rap or nothing um i come from
mariachi my dad my grandpa saying
mariachi my dad everybody that's what i
was gonna do right in their mind i was
gonna be a mariachi singer um
then one time i was singing at
quinceanera i forgot the lyrics to a
song i ran off stage crying i went to
the bathroom i said i'm never singing
mariachi ever again nobody asked me to
sing i hate this you know and then all
of a sudden i'm 15 i'm listening to like
what all my friends are listening to
which is hip-hop
and i needed an outlet i was like was
suffering from depression i didn't know
how to ex like express myself and i just
started writing you know kind of like
poems and stuff and then you know
freestyling and then battle rapping and
then um it just kind of yeah i stopped
battle rapping because one time i i beat
this like this guy he was a cholo and he
was rapping too and then i almost got my
ass beat and then i was just like you
know what this is dangerous like rapping
at house parties and stuff and you know
if you win you lose oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
because you can't do it and not be real
you hit somebody that's something that's
real and they're like this moment
right you know you challenge their
manhood and then there you go you're
about to get yeah i learned a new word
today in spanish
i mean you just add
to any english word
so so are you from los angeles no i'm
originally from san jose raised in san
diego and and everywhere and would you
pick us um i kind of bounced around a
lot i was i was the first
older granddaughter and the first like
american one so like
my family didn't understand why i was
how i was so i kind of was like the
guinea pig to like showing them
i don't know rebellion and like you know
like hanging out with this and that and
everybody exactly yeah exactly so they
would send me off my mom asking you know
she's too much and she sent me to my tia
my tia sent me over there and then i was
just everywhere and in mexico i loved
the
video
that kind of like life
was dope you know it i had innately like
i loved it um which is why i have one
now i have a ranch and i just you know
my little goats and chickens and i love
it but i also understand the importance
of you know i'm in america my son is
american he loves this he's like i love
going to mexico i'm like
where's the rancho in mine uh it's right
it's like about 15 minutes away from
here like yeah it's pretty close
yeah it's cool
i mean if i say it right now
[Music]
so
yeah those are cool ass names aren't
they yeah
yeah
my grandpa was from peguero jalisco
nice pegueros
yeah and uh they on the ranch there
um i went there as a 10 year old boy
and uh the first night we're laying
there there's no screens on the windows
and the minute you lay down here
the mosquitoes go by your ear oh
and they're huge man you turn one on and
you see it and then you're like what the
[__] is that
yeah and it's
all the bugs are bigger in mexico oh
yeah then that one had a little little
vast little belt had a tattoo a little
tattoo like
a bell buckle
and uh how did somebody see you to get
that
initial like spark of
of of hey this girl you know i think we
can do something here i
i used to like
like burn my own cds you know and sell
them i would go to the street sell them
um
i would make my own flyers my own
posters you know i would try to um in
san diego you have to like sell tickets
to like be able to like do a show or
whatever do showcases you end up
performing in front of the 15 people you
brought but you know it just you trust
it's very similar to comedy like i love
watching like a lot of podcasts like
comedians and stuff about you know how
touring is and getting in a van and you
know doing coffee shops and doing all
that stuff like i literally
did it that way you know and that's why
it was so hard of like
building it and i think that's why it'll
it'll make you have a little chip on
your shoulder sometimes when people just
get it easy and you're just like but
then you eventually evolve and you're
like you know what whatever that's their
journey this is my journey and you know
you you kind of like grow with your fan
base and at this point i'm very happy
with with what i got because we have
such a like close-knit community you
know and i was able to make a podcast
make a subscription-based you know
youtube where it's like they support me
so you don't even need a million you
know fans you just need a small amount
that supports you in a community and you
you have a lot of love you know that's
right so so that that could be the
platform for new music especially when
you have you know a lot of subscribers a
lot of people listen it's your you know
tick tock too yeah i'm on yeah i'm on on
everything right now with music with
entertainment like you have to have all
these things
you don't
you suck like if you don't if you don't
have it like nobody's going to be able
to watch you it's so
like uh
saturated saturated yeah and then during
the pandemic like how did what did you
do during that time you have a kid i
think when you have a kid that's young
it's or
it's tough because you know they're not
used to not having
they're not used to staying home or not
used to yeah and they you know it's so
bad they want to go to school but
they're i mean it's not locked down like
there's like you say hey you have to
stay home like to make a kid understand
that it's tough for them dude i was in
the middle of buying my property that
i'm at now like i was in the middle of
that and i it was like where you're too
late like where if anything goes down
like you lost your money so i was like
stuck and i was like now they they're
telling me there's no touring so you're
not really going to go out there and you
know earn money like that or you know i
didn't know what the what i don't have
any other skills like i'm like what am i
going to go do you know like so um it
was hard it was tough but um i'm very
happy that you know we we kind of
survived and we made it work and you
know
i was raised very like you figure it out
like get to work so but you know you
were you know some people are raised not
all of us but some people are raised
that
you can get by with very very little
and you see people you know people that
live big lives you know it's a bit of a
compensation for something but
we could go back to we could go back to
the living where you know my grandmother
would make beans for the week
and if you were hungry you just got
beans and there was some eggs in there
or whatever but it wasn't like
you know where were we going to go eat
everybody eats they go out or
door dash or groundhog
i mean you found something there they
eat all the time yeah
no i uh yeah well my parents both live
in mexico so i
kind of didn't really have any way to
like fall back there was no plan to go
back so it's kind of like i don't really
know what to do um but yeah yeah beans
rice you know now now that we have the
chickens like they lay a lot of eggs i
didn't even realize how many damn eggs i
only have three and my fridge is like
full of eggs and i can't even taste them
because a year ago i got covered and i
lost my freaking sense of taste for eggs
so wow
they taste weird though
brown and white there's like yeah like
white brown if you guys round brown eggs
or come on that's all i buy
eggs what's the difference between the
brown eggs and the white eggs the yellow
the white they think they're better than
the brown ones
[Music]
the yolk is so much richer and so much
tastier than a brown egg than it is in
the white i had a joke here's a joke
that i wrote that you know you know
latinos i always listen to other people
when they order they go huh can we get
three egg white omelets and then can we
get like veggies on the side that dude's
listening
yeah
and the waiter passes by and he goes hey
can we have the yellows
[Laughter]
that's the best i thought it was the
best part
yeah you know so you know like that
that's how the comedy you know yeah yeah
so when you when you started to listen
to music um
who were the people that you who were
the people that you liked
eminem biggie tupac you know um andre
3000 lauryn hill um all the yeah the
good stuff man yeah you know
how do you feel about music nowadays
compared to like did you listen to
hip-hop back in the um
yeah i think i did you know but my but
i'm older so my all my stuff is caught
like i'm caught in the
oldies yeah that's a vibe too though you
know when it's on the plane listen to
like
ice cube where i go to new york i go i
go east coast west coast back and forth
like switch out in in you know you know
and that's that stuff
i mean i did our senior show in 89 when
it started and um i saw
nwa
and i was on the show with vanilla ice
where arsenio
said what's up with the you know uh
going after hammer
which made yeah you know going and i saw
vanilla ice in his
green
the the parachute pants and the whole
green silver thing walked right by me
the whole shape thing on the side
you know i saw
snoop when
in that time in the early 90s
dre
ice cube
you know
i never listened to any of that stuff i
was stuck in the 60s 1670 that's where i
was i stuck
and the only rapper because i wasn't
into rap music
uh when i went to go see you uh
over at the uh
lap factory
they uh be real
they were playing some music oh yeah
yeah and my daughter said
dad
that's be real that's the one you had
because i said pam that's a that's a
nice jam i like it he said well that's
be real that's the guy that was on the
show right
and i never knew that i cared for me he
was good i don't think he really yeah
he's uh yeah a legend huh yeah yeah
definitely i mean especially for
mexican-american and like you know
latinos we don't we don't have that many
that have really crossed over and like
made it that big so it's yeah definitely
and him you know he was trying to change
his voice
and it wasn't working so you know they
said hey let's make this group so
they're like yo man like it doesn't your
your flow doesn't work man and then he
did that nasally thing and then they
said well you know what because he would
he would joke around doing the nasally
thing
and then they said do that thing like
you were doing
and and i mean it's so unique such a
unique
uh voice
he's good uh yeah and you know
there's a there's a lot of stigmas about
weed
that makes you slow or you can't be
intelligent
that dude they smoke weed all day oh
dude yeah when he was on the show in the
parking lot they were in there smoking
just like you see the cheech and chong
movies all smoking there yeah yeah he
rolls the window down smoke blows up his
eyes
right in there he came in here and they
didn't smoke in here but he'd been
smoking all day and
could not have been more intelligent in
making him exactly understand the the
why it works you know who it works for
wheat weed yeah and how when when gill
was a sheriff in the in the at his time
in the 70s so you get this thing in your
head where
the flower part of it you're not really
that comfortable with because having a
joint
was a felony back you know when i first
fell in god that was a single joint was
a felony
i mean no misdemeanor [__] felony
bam you're gone
and
and so over the years it changed and i'm
not a prude i don't give a [__] who does
what's in their body i don't care yeah
and weed has never bothered me just like
alcohol during prohibition
i really didn't care and i still don't
care today but that stigma
yeah where for so long you know i was on
this side of the lawn and i i
i just can't do it i don't care if my
kids do it anybody i don't care my wife
does it i don't nobody bothered but i
just had that statement yeah then i got
introduced to
uh
what the hell the
edibles
oh yeah
gummies and stuff oh yeah
yeah that one's mango and it has tahini
on it nice those are good yeah and uh
edibles are a little strong for me they
they i'm a rapper he's a woman right but
like i don't i don't really smoke that
much i smoke like to sleep sometimes
here and there to record
but when i was a teenager i did right i
use those to uh from a little bit of
pain or uncover go to sleep at night pop
one eat it let's go mimi's nice
yeah
and they're not illegal so it's it's all
good thank you guys
most of my family is and they're fine
yeah right
they're good yeah that's we just came up
with it
makers of the smoothest hitting pipes
and bongs around today's episode is
brought to you by freeze pipe each
freeze pipe product uses freezable
glycerin chambers to cool smoke by
hundreds of degrees pop one of these
glycerin chambers on the freezer for one
hour annis
smoke passes through the icy chamber
it's instantly chilled for a bigger
colder and smoother hit
okay how does the pipe look the pipe
looks like a ray gun from lost in space
but
those were fake ones this one right here
it's cool to the touch but it's not cool
at the handle and it is that easy to use
where you put the stuff in here it goes
through these cylinders and then it
comes out a cool refreshing
hit every time
and how does it feel the smoke out of it
it feels you know what it's smooth it's
incredible so let's say that you were
taking a taxi like in the old days so
the taxi is only right here because in
the old days you would just put the weed
and it didn't go through a chamber but
let's say now you start to take a limo
everywhere okay now you have the cool
limo you got the whole week going
through the cold thing you're not in the
taxi anymore you bumped up to the good
part and then right here is if you took
a sprinter like to go see a concert with
all your friends so now you have the
green in there then it comes through the
limo cylinder where it cools everything
down and by here it's all refreshment
yep refreshments
so how does it feel to be smoked amazing
and i would recommend this
to all of my friends
that
indulge in this
and even to the theans i could put
cilantro in there and be or you know oh
you want something
i would recommend this to all my friends
if you're tired of burning through or
coughing too much when you light up
that's the thing that that thing visit
the freezepipe.com and use the code omg
hi for 10 off that is the freeze the
freeze pipe dot com use the code omg hi
for 10 off and say goodbye
to that harsh
cannabis
smoke
hey when you go in the studio because i
watch that thing on the beatles uh get
is it get back you see that thing yeah
on disney plus right yeah so they go in
the studio
and they don't really have any songs
prepared but they have their guitars and
they would just kind of do this thing
and then they would say a word and the
guy's like oh i like that and through
the three
probably six hours of it you see them
come up with some of the songs that were
their most famous yeah wow
in in a line like in a line a guitar
exists and a thing
and you it's amazing but that's how
that's how rappers go in huh you go in
with kind of
yeah maybe an id you know you're in
there you may wrote some stuff down
trying to find some beats everybody's in
there kind of
smoking and drinking and and and
but it's all
all day sometimes right days yeah
yeah i mean i'm i i'm lucky enough to
like because i'm independent and like
not even like a distributor or anything
i really just work however so like the
other day i just literally brought the
mic to my bed my my pro tools to my bed
i'm in my bed and i'm recording a song
you know and it's like some of my songs
have been recorded
in the randomest places and that's you
know it's wherever your creativity hits
but sometimes it does feel good to get
in a studio and get you know with other
people it's just the vibe to be honest
music ends up just being about
the energy the frequencies the vibe you
know what you want to convey and that's
it when you uh when you started do you
do you see yourself or feel yourself
different because of the experiences
that you had when you first started like
you know kind of like everybody's
wide-eyed you know yeah and do you feel
yourself different enough stronger like
you changed oh yeah the music industry
broke my heart my soul you know what i
mean like people be like oh you know
don't sell your soda bro they got
crushed
it was crushed a long time ago you know
what i mean and then you and then you
rebuild and you kind of rebuild new and
do all that stuff and then you find
happiness like for someone like me like
i'm a lot happier and more content and
i'm like on to i make music because i'm
never going to stop making music i love
it
but you know i do have my eyes set on
you know like more like tv or writing
you know stories or doing any of that
type of stuff because i'm a writer but
i don't know i think you're coming from
mariachi parents and family music
background and then becoming a rapper is
the idea for the show yeah right yeah
yeah and and the realness of
them wanting you to do
that and then you forgetting and then
going out there and saying don't make me
do it again and then turning into
yeah the rapper and the and the person
that you are yeah yeah i agree and those
things
need to be bad girl turns out golden
she's right
just like didn't want to do just like
who was the jazz singer
the uh
oh what year
no no the the big his dad wanted him to
be a cantor
and uh neil diamond neil diamond
and when he didn't become one the family
was upset with him but look what he went
on to do
so when she didn't become a mariachi
she's the bad girl she didn't she didn't
follow what well i mean the armed
robberies didn't help
my bad girl
so then she becomes
you have armed robberies in there
so when i was little yeah when i was a
teenager like i said you know i was
rolling around and i was in a rebellious
kind of like nobody wants me situation
you know kind of victimizing like ah
like you know why am i why am i this
person but um so yeah i did you know i
did some crimes and whatever um what i
am happy about is that i ended up in
juvenile hall right so i had enough time
to like kind of
get my mind straight and be like is this
what i want as an adult i'm about to
turn 18 like is this what i want for the
rest of my life so i will say that i the
rehabilitation part of you know getting
locked up and going to probation and
paying restitution and like everything
that i did
taught me
to
not want to be able to do it for you
yeah and that's why i always thought
like i should help you know at-risk
teens and stuff like that just mostly
because music saved me you know uh going
you know going through all that kind of
helped me out and i i focused you know i
realized it took me
home to my parents at age 17 and said
sign for me get off the streets you'll
end up dead or in prison
so they did
and at 17 i went into the army
and that changed my whole life yeah and
so on you didn't just go to the army you
went to vietnam well i ended up in
combat i ended up in combat oh my god
and so it was uh it matured me gave me a
new appreciation in life i want to do
different things so yeah i can
appreciate everything you've gone
through and just because you're
that side of the fence at one time
doesn't mean you can't change and you've
proven exactly exactly and now you're a
role model for other youth yeah to look
up to yeah and that's one of the reasons
i became a rapper was because i was like
what's the coolest thing you can do
right like what's the coolest thing you
could be a rapper and have this baller
life then the teens will listen to me
because they're not going to listen to
me if i'm one more adult like you needed
a you know but if i be have the life
they want and then i go hey you know
that's part of the reason why my son
listens to me you know he's like whoa
like you know it's like he thinks tick
tock tick tocks are cool i go get a
million followers on tick tock he thinks
youtube you know anything because i'm
like i'm gonna show you i could do that
and then i'm gonna show you why you need
to listen to me and now he's you know
getting getting getting it together but
you know kids could be spoiled or
whatever so you gotta think no no of
course a better way but but it's good to
see like have you have you done shows in
mexico
yeah yeah i did a few oh [__] what's
that like
i cried i cried uh mostly because i
didn't i didn't do any shows in mexico i
i was very like
scared to go and nobody care about me
because that's so much of a big part of
my identity imagine you know you're out
here and you're repping to everybody how
mexican you are and then you go to
mexico and nobody cares you're like oh
my god
so when i showed up and there was a like
a crowd like a huge i was like
you know so it was yeah it was it was
beautiful i got to share with my
girlfriend and um you know i i told her
to kiss me on stage because i just
always felt like that part you know like
the homophobia the all the things and
it's like it all kind of comes full
circle and you finally feel like
you know you did it and um it was it was
amazing do you think that uh
do you think that people
who are from latin american countries
are more homophobic
uh than people of the united states
i don't know because i don't i don't
subscribe to mexico i stay out of mexico
it's impossible i'll give you an example
well you don't subscribe to mexico oh
wow where's the subscription
with some eggs
i've been down there
all my years in law enforcement i had to
go down there but the yellows are good
and it's not safe down there so i i just
don't have holy [__] this is news to me
i don't have anything to do
you know i'll stay on this side of the
board he went to the american embassy
i mean i've had
i've had guns pulled on me by bad guys
and by cops so you're saying that you
don't like mexico i'm saying that i
don't like to travel to mexico
i love everything about my culture what
if i carried you i love you you got that
strong back i'm rolling
just to see you do it brother
i'm rolling i don't want to trip
i get that though like because dudes do
you know you you do have it a little
harder and i gotta say that about
you know i had a chip on my shoulder
going into the wrap industry or going
into anything uh about like men have it
easier right but then there is certain
places where as a woman i had to be like
okay bet like i do have this going for
me which is you know i could kind of go
to san jose i can go to san diego i can
perform wherever if i was a dude they're
going to check me and they're going to
be like well you know where you from and
you know all these things so i get it
you know i could be harder and just here
here dude is it more acceptable or not
and i think i've talked about it on the
air uh my son
is gay
and it didn't make that's my son i love
him i don't care what he i support him
whatever he does
awesome and how did you find out that uh
i i came home from panama i've been in
panama for two weeks
the family met me at the airport don't
put that in there i'm [__] you know
i'm getting drunk what'd you put at the
bottom of the beer okay
i arrived back at lax i got in the car
uh
the kids were in one car my wife says
come on her and i were in another car we
started leaving i put it in gear
and she says stop i got to get something
off my chest right now
and i said oh [__] i just got back now
what's the problem
and she says your son came out of the
closet
and i said and
that's it
i said hey he's not into dope he's not a
criminal he's not bad he's a good kid
he's got a good heart if that's the
worst that's gonna happen in his life so
be it i'm i'm lucky yeah i love my son
and and that's just the way it was
i went home
that night
and i wrote a letter i cut him off right
now i wrote a letter to my family
and to close friends saying
my son has come out of the closet and
this is him
and he's my son i love him nothing has
changed if anybody has a problem
feel free to contact me
and we can discuss this and so i've been
supportive of
everything you're gonna make me cry i'm
talking to my deputy i haven't come out
yet
no i know but but but you see i mean
uh yeah and i don't think movies they've
all movies
i even hit him up now if he has any
single friends that have good-looking
fathers you know either
but they're harder they're harder
because it's just
you know everybody you know when you
when you're growing up they tell you be
a man you know that whole but people
have to live their happiest life i
wouldn't trade him
for anything he's a good beautiful yeah
that really that's yeah he's now [__] i
think he's 43 now 44. oh i hate him
[Laughter]
go follow him on instagram i love the
kid
yeah that's awesome
yeah
damn
i mean yeah it just you know it sucks
with social media and how many people
get to put certain things out there
which don't help our communities because
like i was saying you know the other day
i went to mexico and i was like you know
people saying that mexico's mad
homophobic i'm like me being gay
enjoying myself right and then i get a
bunch of
you know latino people being like you
you can't speak on how difficult it is
and i'm like i mean yes but at the same
time i'm tired of people making it seem
like you know like our we're just like
neanderthals i can't understand the
concept of you know what i mean so it's
hard to represent do it right you know
not necessarily
alienate people but at the same time not
make it it's it's hard right now it's
real representation right right you know
because because um even with like you
know caitlyn jenner
that wanted to run for governor and the
whole you know it was tough for
it's tougher that
you know
yeah he
yeah he's good he
like roosevelt grew or took up knitting
i don't know crocheting knitting
whatever you call that [__]
needlepoint needlepoint well my son
started doing that just
wanted something to do so he's he's at
home this just happened within the last
four or five years
and he starts doing that [__] and all of
a sudden he got an idea and he started
making
i call him [__] socks it's like a job
it's like a jock strap it's all knitted
and he can make them for
anything you want
with mexican design american flag
you know mickey mouse anything and he
and he does this [__]
and he's mickey mouse where the ears are
he'll put ears on him he'll put all
kinds of stuff on there
babe for yourself
sold and published in european magazines
he just sent a piece off to australia
the other day they've used some of those
people that come out on a
runway
rupaul project runway yeah
some of those
people have purchased from him and he
does it he started out just as a hobby
and and he does that so we had a regular
job but he does this outside just just
as a hobby yeah i'm trying to find his
page name so we can shout him out house
of [__] house of [__] or something
like that okay
that's awesome i'll confirm and then
i'll let you but you know you know kids
um
you know they're suicidal suicide over
there
you know 100 yeah of being rejected or
yeah their parents the way their parents
handle you know handle that yeah i mean
florida just passed didn't they like
they're proposing or something about
like not mentioning lgbt and like
elementary or whatever or like in school
and i just feel like you know
it's kind of ignorant to not know that
kids are gonna learn about some of this
stuff unfortunately you know i think a
lot of the times that people get like
essayed or anything like that it's
because they don't know about what's
going on so i do think sometimes it's
like
you know like teaching correctly because
if you don't then guess who's going to
teach them somebody who went through
trauma from someone else who went
through trauma and then it just gets a
little [__] up but um
yeah i think people should be more
inclusive and just um
understand and respect people's
boundaries because um if not you know
but you know
yeah when raps started it became you
know the way they um
they denigrated women you know
in the beginning of it and then as it
gets older and it becomes around and
more rappers pop up then they start to
put the way that they the way that they
think in there and now you have
you know independent rappers and you
have rappers like that old school
rappers but also you know people like
you that can do it and do it from what
you feel in your heart yeah um because i
don't think i don't think the way that
those guys felt about women was women
was necessarily what was them it was
just kind of the thing that they used
right a hook that they used but when you
come from a real place
and you see it that you can you know
affect a kid that's maybe 15 yeah it's
going to get to that point where
they're gonna start to know who they can
trust or can they you know you're living
with the secret that you don't want
anybody to find out that's that's all
tough stuff yeah yeah definitely and i'm
very you know inclusive and i have a son
so i always you know when i you know
when they get to an age where you're
like oh is there a little girl you like
or whatever and i'm like or anyone you
know if you want to be he's like i'm not
gay mom i'm like oh sorry i'm just
trying to make sure if there's any you
know what i mean because yeah you don't
you don't understand some of those
feelings all i asked my son and i told
him when you know and the next day was
his birthday oh no and i remember being
in bed my wife says go over there and
talk to me sit in the living room all by
himself you know because he knew
my wife was going to tell me on the way
home right
and
so he said i said no he knows where i'm
at nothing has changed
and you can give him this card
and i had a birthday card for him and
i'd already written something in there
and uh
so he then came in there
and i said i don't care what you do
whatever you do in life you know i'm
here to support you son
uh
it is what it is you know does that mean
i have to stop telling gay jokes and he
said no did you write a little poem in
there like roses are red
my glasses green you had the smallest
i've ever seen
i just don't want to see on the jerry
springer show right now
don't don't do that and whatever you do
we're just here to give you love and
support
and so that's what we did and everything
is everything's been been good for him i
think but he doesn't live at home still
does he no okay it's awesome that's
awesome
with my parents i wouldn't
i didn't even come out you know what i
mean like i made a career in the life
and eventually i just was like oh by the
way this is my girlfriend now because i
was married to a man before and i had a
baby and so like i've kind of like lived
my life and then just kind of didn't
really need my print my god kick i got
kicked out when i was like 16. so it's
like there's really no reason that i
have to
say anything but but
you didn't you didn't want to have to
either
i didn't but my dad honestly i mean you
know like people make some mistakes in
their life that you just kind of are
like do you really have
any say like you know you've done your
things i don't know what the [__] but um
yeah i
i don't really know
i don't know about the coming out side
of things like you know except for my
brother i did have to like kind of i
think my brother was the scariest person
that you know but he he loves me he
loves my my girl my family you know
and explaining it to my son
me and my son my son and i joke about it
all the time i can remember a few years
back where he came he says dad a friend
of my daughters and i'm not going to
mention any names but a friend of my
daughters had just had
uh
breast augmentation she had enhancements
she had some put in here he says dad
she showed them to me she was showing my
the girls and she showed them to me
she's not you're gay it's not going to
make a difference you showed me i said
son run back and tell her your dad's gay
too
let's do this
[Laughter]
is that part of your act you're working
on yeah
you go
by the way i found the instagram it's
house of [__] also h-a-u-s house of
batch on instagram for your your
sunscreen yeah he's um have you ever
have you ever seen or or heard anything
in your in your while you're sleeping
any kind of paranormal ghosts or voices
or anything
[Music]
no i mean i try not to i think because
we're from we're from that good we're
good i don't have to move away then yeah
he's into that [__] not me i totally
yeah i
i feel like my you know like my mom's
always been like you know those because
like don't look for what you're not you
what you don't want to find right so i
think she was talking more about drawers
she was talking about drawers and [__]
but
yeah no so i just kind of try to you
know i don't know stay away from him i
mean straight away from the the the
stuff like that but who knows maybe
maybe something's going on i just don't
look you know we're probably coexisting
if i hear something see something that i
shouldn't see turn the other way and get
out of here i mean right now in la i
think you have more things to be worried
about than a couple ghosts i think you
know the home invasions and burglaries
and everything like that you know but
also people don't people do not um
they're not aware of their surroundings
most of the time
they drive they don't look around they
park they don't look around
there was a lady that opened her door
and these two guys ran in her house and
you know they said she didn't see
anybody you know she didn't pay
attention to what was around her yeah
that's not the only thing i pound into
my family for sure
every day
know your surroundings don't come out
alone make sure and lit check this
people around
yeah so this is a picture i took with me
in sinbad
and look at the hand there's another
hand by my hand
oh shoot
yeah dude that's not yours though you
didn't like wiggle real quick
oh yeah no thanks
he's got a couple of these like really
yeah i can tell you right now this guy
the more i hang around with him the more
i'm around him he's going to scare the
[__] out of me one day we're going to be
in a car together or something he's like
hey gil remember that picture
now would come to you
this guy was behind you holding your
waist
[Laughter]
i mean they're they're all around me
and what do you how do you feel about
that um
you know i moved into the south side in
uh in los angeles said that uh
that
i would i would hear things that in the
middle of the night but
it's a trip
not so much anyone had somebody come in
but it was getting to the point where
if they were just like in this area then
i started to go there
they started to get on this side and i
would be watching tv like somebody just
walked by or just
and you'd see it but then i had somebody
come in and
clean most of it out
but it's a huge part of the car it's a
huge part of our culture i wish it
wasn't a huge part of mine i only have
one question for you clean most of it
out why don't you have them clean it all
out because sometimes they don't they
you know they don't leave most of them
they had a
lady was in there a long time oh man
i mean look the the the ranch i got is
pretty old you know what i mean and that
was one of the first things that i i did
was kind of like google and look up if
there's not been anything
um and yeah it was it was definitely
scary at the beginning
i can't say necessarily that i've you
know
felt anything um which is funny because
like i've lived in like smaller places
that i've
maybe felt a little weird when i go to
the kitchen or whatever but like
considering how big this place is i
i feel okay yeah i mean i might go home
today and now i'm like acceptable to
like
get out i'm like oh my god george told
me that
yeah but sometimes
i don't know it just depends what you
were brought up i wish my grandma hadn't
put that
in my
put that evil under my head my mom my
mom was a disciplinarian in the house my
dad was kind of quiet
kids were up to my mom and
so my mom didn't mess around with it
kaku is going to get you there yorona is
going to get you her chocolate chingasa
was going to get you right now
she ruled with an iron fist
yeah she was a tough tough old lady
are you how are you with your son what
kind of uh parenting what kind of
parenting dude what school um
i
i'm not you know as funny as i got i got
into it on social media with like all
the anti-chancla people and i get it i
totally get it
but i thought it was funny that they
were attacking me at a time when i
literally have a song that says [__] a
chancla you know
even though like i do believe in being
disciplined and you know having all
these things i don't think necessarily
beating children is gonna teach them you
know what i mean um but i do think that
having a healthy fear and disappointing
you is a is a way better teacher than um
having a fear of you right personally
you know like i don't want to hurt my
kid i just want him to not want to
disappoint me i'm very open with him i
talk with him a lot like you know and
and i have to because my job consists of
like
strippers cussing you know like all the
stuff i rap about like everything i talk
about like i have to be open with him
because
nothing sucks more than growing up
thinking your parents are like up here
and then they just like disappoint you
that's right around the time when you
just decide to be a fuck-up i mean
that's what happened to me but um but
yeah so i just try to be as open as i
can and talk to him but
naturally there's gonna be some little
bit of being spoiled for him you know
he's a little spoiled but but also i
think part of it is um who their friends
are yeah because you can protect them so
much in your house where you say hey
would i tell you i don't want you to do
that or i want you looking at that but
then when they go to someone else's
house now you know you're not around
there and if they see it that i always
say like if they see it they can't unsee
it
and uh
some of these little badass kids bro
like yeah i'd be like i don't like that
little kid there's a problem you see him
right now there's some kid that always
comes over and he's always wanting to be
barefoot all the [__] time like you
put some
they're all slapping on the floor and
[__] i'm like what's going on all out
there's a difference
in in when i grew up you go down a
friend's house and his parents were just
like your parents you know they want you
to go in the house they they weren't
going to mess around they're going to
discipline just like your parents and
everybody took care of it it was a
village right that put it together now
with
so many people being multicultural and
now we're in a different era so these
parents over here don't believe in
discipline at all you know okay
i'm gonna count to ten and you better
move you know right ching god you know
back then you wouldn't get no count to
one right you know so they they do
things differently now and it's hard
for them to adjust so now you know
these kids hang with
these kids over here where there's no
discipline in the house
and so to come over here where there is
then
you're outcasted being a bad person yeah
i've had to end friendships over over
that type of stuff like you know like
some some kids are so bad that it gets
to a point where it's like okay i'm not
i can't keep being friends with you your
kid is like you know whatever be parent
however you want but sometimes
you know one little kid kept kicking my
son in the balls i'm like bro i'm not
gonna keep on being you know what i mean
like as much as we could be friends like
i need you to like you know figure it
out you know and yeah i don't i think um
people should be consistent with their
parenting the problem is a lot of times
maybe people want to
you know they're not so tough then all
of a sudden watching god and then all of
a sudden they're not tough and then you
know he's like
i think the confrontation is is
different these days sure you know you
could video it you could somebody could
video with that no not another video in
it and say something that you know it's
not right but
i think that um
because you used to be able to tell a
kid hey listen you know leave my house
or whatever and now i think they they
talk back to you they're
you know they got their whole
attitude that the kids kind of didn't
have
yeah before like they think every kid's
gonna think they know everything but
just the
the pressure of them even being on
social media
and being at that age
is having access to everything on the
internet yeah i'm not sure i would have
i don't think i would like that
yeah no you take away their phone their
friends have phones
and all these kids have phones oh yeah
yeah i took away my kids computer the
other day and i told them to get like
then i was like you better finish your
homework he's like i need my computer to
finish my homework [__]
i walk out off dramatic
and that's the thing about him though
too is he's really funny like he's
actually funny like you know what i mean
like he got that good you know and then
um and then also he
he doesn't uh he doesn't really talk
back like that you know that's great
he's i don't know what he does to his
dad but i'm a little bit more you know
yeah and stuff so i don't know i got a
good kid i'm i'm very happy with you
know where we're at he doesn't flinch
when he's not a teenager he doesn't go
like this no no definitely not uh i
noticed uh i looked on your site there
but you don't have any shows scheduled
right because of everything that's been
happening i think right um i have a tour
right now that's gonna come up um in
like april we haven't announced yet um
but definitely like a national run i
have um shows in spain shows in mexico
awesome wow
it's it's it's good you know but at the
same time we don't know what's going on
with kovid right now it's a really scary
time because even like with brands or
with things like that like they're like
well we don't know we don't want to lock
down and then all of a sudden and you
know so it's a weird time to be
navigating but we're good okay um
do you remember when champion made like
school shorts
t-shirts sure jerseys back in the day
the quality
or the look of it was very uniform
you know they had the little white thing
with your with your school and a little
white thing well i don't know if you put
your number in there your name or
whatever nobody cares about that
and or the socks were a little bit not
of the highest i would say back then
right champion
her jacket is champion and it's like
blue but it's got a purple tinge to it
it's like a junebug
like like a sheen matches her hair
no i know but i mean you know
like i'm thinking did they make it like
that or did she put wash it with it
did i wash it with magic it's beautiful
but champion there they are i've seen
more champion stuff like they're they've
elevated the the company yeah i think
they i think there's a lot of cool
company like stuff like that i remember
i hit a fila a long last time before
they popped back up yeah and i was like
i have a feeling like fema's gonna come
back and that my you know she kind of
waves was like yo what's up with fila um
but yeah they popped up super hard like
all these brands are i think everybody
has the love for nostalgia that's why
like oldies will never go out of style
you know champion's been around forever
yeah they used to make all the high
school and collegiate football jerseys
baseball jerseys yeah yeah no they're
they're awesome it's crazy
i love it you have a deal with them or
no
i just
bought it
no it looks great
thank you doesn't it your beer is good
it's good yeah i chug this [__] yeah i
brought up some more i don't know if you
saw this one really oh thank you yeah
yeah no i'm really gonna actually end up
crying but um i had a dude that worked
at stone brewery for uh
for like 30 years he was the brewer so i
had a list of stuff when we had the
meeting to talk about the beer i said
all right can you make a beer that
tastes like remember the 50 50 bar the
dreamsicle orange and cream in the
middle the guy goes oh yeah yeah yeah i
can make a beer that tastes like that we
have it there somewhere out here i said
can you make a anyone made out of a
hibiscus hamika
a beer sour beer people use it as a as a
mixer but that one's great some people
love it some people don't like it
this one tastes like beer that one is uh
that's a little that's the the lager and
then there's one katina called like a
grapefruit
yeah i like that one grapefruit taste
that's my favorite one right here what's
that one same one
okay got the mexican lager a little mixy
that's dope more lagers i brought out
too i love it and then we use chicano
artists on the on the can yeah the art
on it is super dope they're all all four
cans have different sets of hard on them
you know i said this beer is too good
for a brown paper bag
this is nice no it looks beautiful for
sure
um so who's the guy on the front
yeah we don't want to put grape because
you wouldn't see my name uh but uh yeah
it's been doing it's been doing pretty
good a couple restaurants uh
right in torrance and in hermosa beach
and the car tried to drive through
the car tried to drive through yeah
the oh yeah we did huh it did
some your restaurant you don't even know
about it no no some lady was in the
afternoon was all bail and she ran over
the curb and hit a jogger and then
crashed into my restaurant oh my god
i said two tacos and carnitas to go
please
that way there was a taco place wait
where were we at where it said like pick
up your like pick up
tacos yeah i have the uh doordash
yeah you don't remember you embarrassing
podcast
you're from downtown don't come here
you're not going to remember
no yeah yeah i mean
that's crazy because i remember i used
to watch the show so much that like my
kid barely when he barely would learn
how to talk yeah he would like it was
time for bed and he'd go judge judge and
i was like like we would we would dead
ass watch the [__] show
yeah i can still watch it yeah no yeah
of course you know when we started to do
that show we started doing that comfort
zone yeah exactly no show had gone
beyond
you know two episodes or three episodes
that one's 120.
and it's still on almost 20 years um
but
you know some you know some people they
said did you know that you were
i did so all those stories came from
either real life or real names or and
real situations to me
or to some of the people in the show and
i think that if
at that time you could do a show that
you're just hired as an actor i wasn't
so um some shows come and go they might
they might do a hundred episodes but
they don't get the recycling of the like
my show has over the last you know 15
years that it's been
been off yeah it's all the time and we
were and we knew we were doing that
and in the beginning uh it was a little
bit more adult
and then when i was you know i was
married and said my wife my wife said do
you what are you guys doing with this
script like it's [__] awful man
something like dick jokes and all that
[__] like what and then she goes okay
that's kind of how they do it
so she said i mean the other guy bruce i
had a daughter that was young and my
daughter mine was like five or six she
goes so you so you want to make a show
with this guy
that your own kids can watch
and
in in
reducing those that humor to more of a
family but edgy humor is i think the
reason it survived all these years and
by the way his daughter just sold a show
i saw
skyler yeah
she said to uh cbs what show is that
that's called uh it's what is it
uh unplanned in akron it's a teen parent
comedy man how about that
that's where i want to go
i'm gonna speak that into position where
do you want to go
yeah tv like i want to write i want to
definitely like when i was on queen of
the south i was a character and i like
you know like i was just kind of trying
to get my feet wet and then i was kind
of trying to help out with
some of the
chicano things you know you know when
sometimes on the script just a little
you know this or that and i was just
like hey man maybe we say maybe you know
change and uh i i i found out that like
that could be a good passion for me
because i don't want to be a rapper
forever like [__] you know so yeah i
feel like that would be great well i
want to go i have a show that i sold to
amazon that we did the pilot we'll know
by
february 1st if not sooner
and you would be good for that show oh
[__]
am i going to leave here with a job
if they find out about the show not for
the other one with my daughter you're
not right for that one oh but
uh the other one is like an hour for
amazon and you'd be
perfect because we met annie right
so annie
you know you're like that the whole but
that's how annie is you know the
daughter of my show is like
loud and you know she knows her strong
she knows her but she really runs the
house i think i do but she does
and i mean you you fit in perfect with
us that's dope
yeah that'd be [__] amazing and you
know while you're sung but get some [__]
socks
with a beanie and purple hair on the
but you're right you know some people
don't have uh
you know when the when they're when
they're kind of in that in the light of
it like what the child likes when you
have the hammer like some people do not
know how to use the power when they have
it so when they don't have it
they don't have anything because it's
the early on when you should be using it
yeah so when you have when you have
people listening to you yeah and they
want to hear what you have what else do
you have you know what they really want
to understand it versus like getting
toward the end and go what am i going to
do now start producing like you're like
you're on the right track because you
know
and that's a that's a great life too
like you know that that that they know
that the that
queen of south yeah queen of the south
by where you're going acting doing 100
episodes that's [__] beautiful yeah
so easy
you're you're visual but you're doing
something
outside of your profession yeah outside
of rapping outside of stand-up you know
i had the tv show so people people used
to watch a tv show
didn't even know i did stand up there's
some people that still today that they'd
go oh
yeah no way where are you going for your
show i said i do stan you you do i
didn't know that
no yeah i knew that's the idea obviously
i knew you did stand up because i'd gone
to see you multiple times i knew your tv
show because i loved your tv show
what i did know about you was podcasts i
had no idea until the day that i stepped
in here for the first time yeah i had no
idea you were doing a podcast we had
just started you know we just started
doing it but but i had another deal and
the guy was like making me do
like like practice shows
what like three years for podcasts
and i was like yo man let's do that who
the hell's that guy
yeah right
that's it man when we're gonna start
aaron no i think we should do a couple
it's saying no i love that you know it
has to be off the cuff these guys yeah
these guys have been these guys have
been great it's been a year almost a
year it'll be a uh a year come march
first so we're coming up on it
yeah yeah with mine i mean i just i've
never really had guests and stuff like
that like i just kind of talk um but
sometimes i do wonder about that like
you know that that's cool like cool
conversations all the time learn stuff
you know like being a like cop for how
long like forever 38 years that's crazy
like you must have mad stories
look at here i am with george and grant
and you this is this is the bomb this is
the best part of my career what was the
other big arrest you had you had you
only caught the nightstalker right you
saw the documentary on netflix crazy
what i knew when i walked in and you
said it
he was a detective he they caught
richard ramirez what
that's crazy look at him take a chance
yeah you have to go home check it out on
netflix
you got to watch that thing oh that's
good
crazy it's a good documentary and there
was no citizen out back then so like you
can't even
no yeah
no that was awesome you saw some smoke
you're like [__]
yeah yeah
that's crazy the citizen
that thing is raw huh
that's scary bro but the neighbor next
door is
does anybody want my cat
yeah oh the next thing that nick
uh are you on that yeah oh yeah yeah and
then they're always like coyotes
yeah
my car lit on fire and it was all over
and people knew where i live because of
the it was on the citizen app and i like
instagrammed it and people were like i
know where you're at and i was like [__]
i was you know hey are they crazy are
they crazy man like like stalkers that
you get
or that's i don't know stalkers but
people that the tweakers are like the
the the people you know there's been a
couple that you know one time i wake up
i go outside i look at it there was a
note written and a sarape for some
reason and a belt buckle and i was just
a little confused i was like what the
[__] is going on but the guy wrote his
real name so we went on facebook found
him
uh googled him found like meth challenge
what you call it like charges or
whatever like you know whatever and then
yeah he was just talking about like you
know i can't i can't
i can't have run from the fact that you
know we have kids together and he's
we're we're supposed to be together and
then i look at my cameras and he was
outside for three hours
and i had just installed the gate at
that time at my other house and yeah he
was just out there and i'm just like
how do you you know what i mean like
nowadays like how do you [__] so i've
had a few did he go away or did you have
to get call
so i called the cops the cop said they
can't really do anything unless he
actually does something or like walks in
my house and then i was just kind of
yeah i can't do anything right
yeah they were like you you know like if
he if he comes on the property then you
can tell i'm like i'm gonna shoot him by
that time like he's gonna be gone
but um
yeah and then um i really like my
brother's very overprotective and he was
like you know don't contact him but i
was like i think i have to just maybe
because he needs me to tell him because
my brother was telling him like you know
don't don't hit her up blah blah blah
he's like you you're a hater you're
standing in our way i'm going to have to
you know like finish you and i'm like oh
hell no now my brother's in yeah i let
him know he went away a little bit but
um it happens a lot i think with with
girls and drugs and people get a little
little you know there's crazy zombies
like they know you yeah
no but also they think they know you and
they i mean they don't but in their
heads and their heads yeah who's the
famous uh female actress the one that
uh joanie foss julie foster jolene
foster
jody jody she famous stalker i'm not i
don't even know the reason yeah there
was a stalker and they
caught him on her property and not once
but multiple times trying to break in he
had a knife and you wouldn't leave her
alone but what's the deal with that with
cops like why can't like you can't like
nothing can happen like unless they come
and actually hurt you well it it it
depends
right now it depends who the district
attorney is what they're filing you know
whether a misdemeanor or felony
but
they break into your they get in your
property it's nothing more than a
trespass that's a misdemeanor oh hell no
so what can you do about you know
missing now they break into your house
now it's a burglary so now it's a felony
but
today's society and the new
anti-social
cop thing you know the new d.a right now
is unless it's violence i mean the
felonies being
prosecuted as a misdemeanor so still
nothing i know he's doing all this petty
theft [__] right guys are copping out
the burglars they go in your house they
steal your [__] they catch you
they take you to the station you cop out
yes i did it
and they said okay we got it all down
give you a ticket say okay appear in
court you don't even stay in jail they
cite you out of jail
i hate that i like yeah i don't know
unless there's violence it's kind of
tough
maybe i need to get drunk
but they started letting out i think the
less
the non-violent the non-violence yeah
i commented about that because somebody
just posted something about you know and
i was like you know there needs to be
harsher punishment on crimes you know in
california oh my god it was a it was
like it was like a latin word like meme
page
oh my god the comments like i'm talking
about you know sometimes it feels like
the entire community is coming after you
and it's just like the thing is because
they're like disproportionately brown
and black and all this stuff and it's
like i get it i understand that and i
didn't say lock every brown person up i
said crime because it is getting to a
point where
you know what i mean like it even
doesn't even help whenever you're
watching all these videos on on on
social media and it's if it happens to
be somebody then i'm like i feel like it
affects us even more because now
everybody gets to say that like all the
trumpers get to say you know that's what
you guys are doing and it's like oh this
is bad marketing for us we need to we
need to look great right now do you
think that uh do you think that kids
that that play
like i don't know i sound like a
thousand years old but i remember i went
to my friend's house and he had these
teenage daughters and they were going
you from upstairs you'd hear
that you [__] [__] [__]
you're like hey dude what's up what's
going on up there oh my god hey
hey they're grand theft auto yeah like
they yell you know they cuss and they
yell yeah and i mean yeah it's fun it's
i mean it's fun but at some point
because that [__] is so it's so
realistic get me off my soapbox
listen don't crash that don't don't i
should though
i i've
attended classes and i've lectured
people you are from everything you are
from your environment you are who your
friends who you associate with to you
are what you eat mexicans in esl i i
went to a class at
uh speaker at cal state l.a this doctor
got up there and said the reason
mexicans have so much trouble is because
of all the carbohydrates all the
starches in their diet that's what leads
to their problems and it is such
horrible do you think it is oh i think
that guy no i don't i think when you
said right now they're upstairs saying
oh [__] get you it's the parents
why are the parents allowing them to get
away with that [__] yeah yelling and
screaming like that up on top
you know you you can't you can't do that
and i mean and if they're they're over
they're over 21 for the most part why do
you think that is i think because my son
right now stop [__] because they're
not yeah
but if you tell them not to
then i don't know do you tell them not
to
[__] yes you tell them not to one time
my mom used to call me mussolini with my
kids
and i didn't have to do [__] to them
they were disciplined they were good
they're full of love now
and and i didn't beat the [__] out of
them
you know i i really didn't i i spanked
my son one time in his life
and my family you'd have fun
he's going to listen to this and he'll
say george my boo's going out we're
gonna cut that we're
so
he had taken my sacks
he wanted to play saxophone i'm an old
saxophone player oh
he wanted to learn how to play his place
actually started taking it to school and
i said son
whatever you do
you take it out when it's time to
practice in school don't take it out to
mess around with it at all so he came
back
and i want to look at the sax one time
and i saw it
and the keys were bent
and i put it together and i said and i
could see where they were bent and where
air was leaking
come here it was tender
i said come here son i said
you took this out didn't you and he
popped out yeah i did and then i dropped
it then i'm sorry
i said come here let's go in the room
and by the time i got back from the room
my daughters were crying my wife was
crying you'd have thought that i had
tortured the kid in there and i didn't
you know i said you can't do this i told
you not to do this
give him one on the butt
that was it the end of it
and
i didn't have to do that [__] but my
kids knew that don't mess with dad
yeah you know and when i said so to have
them do that and have them yell like
that
it's
that in and of itself
it's the family and then that that
family is going to sit there and blame
the company that makes the game right
it's their fault for making it no
it's your fault for not taking care of
the problem right there now
even if you made it the rule like no kid
under 18 complete they're they'll
they're gonna do it anyways yeah of
course and i i think those they're
pretty violent like i was never really a
gun person or anything like that but
yeah and watching kids play that that's
it's
it's pretty violent
i mean but kids are gonna cuss no matter
what like my son plays basketball
video games you know and they'll be
yelling at each other whatever but i do
go in there like sometimes they rag on
each other like they're like you know
whatever bullying each other kind of and
i go in there and i'm like what is up
with you i'm like what are you saying
he's like you should hear what he's
saying i'm like are you guys friends i'm
like are you guys like what this is
terrible like you guys have a toxic
relationship friendship here like with
pick better friends um but yeah i think
sometimes yeah it is up to the parents
to go up to them and be like should be a
cool mom
yeah i i gotta tell you and i can say
this
i don't think the family will give you
the funny we have a mom that's like on
their kid's side hey my kid said he
didn't do it i believe him he didn't do
it
and you go did you do it i didn't do it
but you know you're standing for the
right thing yeah and a lot of times our
parents are just like he
i didn't do it well he said you you
believe them like what chance do you
have
to a relationship when they go he did
this no i didn't and then you said he's
saying you did it i believe that you i
mean that's that's huge yeah you have to
have a balance definitely my kid got in
trouble for selling snacks at school
um and i was kind of like something yeah
that's entrepreneurs
you can't do that yeah apparently they
want to they won't have a monopoly on
the snack age going on that was the case
when i was selling edibles he was i mean
i mean if you were in the oh shoot what
was he selling candies um next thing you
know a headline like snow wants her to
sell drugs no um he was selling yeah he
was selling like candy apparently so
it's funny because i did this when i was
little like you know i always used to
sell snacks or whatever my mom sold like
you know elotes and nachos and whatever
so um growing up i i figured i could do
it and then now my son came home and was
like hey what if i you know sold sodas
first she wanted to sell sodas and i was
like well that seems heavy i'm like that
seems heavy then you gotta keep it cold
i'm like that doesn't seem like a smart
business he's like what about snacks
like you know people like hot cheetos i
was like okay you know let's go and i
taught i took it as a time to teach him
about you know so i took him to costco
and i was like well you gotta look at
what per item you know per you know
because it says exactly and then um yeah
so i was like and then he goes oh but i
want these bigger bags they're like two
dollars i'm like well these are a dollar
i'm like and there's more chances kids
are gonna have one dollar than two
dollars and if they have two dollars
they could buy two of them and you just
profited 140 cents which would be you
know what i mean i was just kind of
trying to teach him i took it as more of
an entrepreneur lesson i guess i didn't
realize that i'm helping him break the
school law um so when he you know he
made a lot of money he kind of got cocky
i'm kind of glad they stopped him
because he was getting a little
nobody's making more money than me he's
like making it rain in his room
i'm just like you need to stop so yeah i
needed to kind of he needed to get
humbled and um so right now that's what
he's going through but i wouldn't get
him in trouble i told him i was like if
you get in trouble i don't i don't
necessarily agree with you know the
school but um
yeah and you're never going to stop what
they learned in school you know around
their friends school card they
i've got a five-year-old and a
nine-year-old
grand grandchildren their boys they go
to the same school
and so they learned the word
somebody said fuck.
not a good word for them to use so
my my daughter told him hey that's not a
word you will be using don't you ever
use that word that's not a nice word yet
it's okay nipped in the bud
so a couple of days later
the nine-year-old tells mom
uh i just heard roby i heard my brother
say and my daughter heard it
and she says what did you just say
he says he said i didn't say nothing mom
and she just i heard you and he said
okay all i said was [__] i didn't say
the whole word just
no you can't do that you say [__] i'm
going to get that
bar of soap
your mouth is going to be washed out
you know so he hadn't said it again he
he stopped saying it
yeah i mean his grandfather was proud of
him you know he
could get him son
who have you uh who have you met that
you admired growing up
oh man
because uh
besides george no no exactly i didn't
want to come off as like you know
kissing ass or whatever but no real [__]
i'll we'll get to that right now but
also uh lauren hill um
cried so the first time i was like
walking up to her and i just i remember
just being like thank you and i shook
her hand and like ran away and cried
which was kind of like weird so then the
second time i met her i got to at least
get like oh my god i'm such a big fan
and like i think i've already met her
like three times now so i'm just like
working my way up to saying like a full
paragraph
uh yeah she was nice um
yeah and i got like a like a signed um
set list which now like because fans
will walk up to me with my set list and
i'll sign in i don't think much of it
you know but when i got hers i was like
oh my god you know like this is [__]
amazing um so yeah and uh yeah no
definitely george like real [__] like
not even just kissing your ass or
whatever like you cristela angela
johnson like all
the latino like you know
mexican-american like comedians and like
people who have worked on stuff
to me being a proud american has been
such a identity and like such a thing
for me that it's like when you see the
people who have been doing the work
before you you're just like
well you know when i started you know
there wasn't a lot of us but also the
the
idea of latinos was like we were easy
pickings
and i didn't start out to be like the
way i ended up you know even political
or
family you know my stuff was about stuff
that didn't mean anything to me
for
and then it's when i started to see what
latinos were and how we were being
treated i started then i started to do
that in the 90s and that kind of changed
the way that
um
i approached comedy but helped me get a
more of a following about something that
was real you know yeah yeah not just
uh
us as the as the joke you know instead
of instead of having to wait it having a
way to do it so in 1979
when i started
in the summer um
there was a guy's name was like billy
brown little dude he ended up doing a
few movies and stuff and he was talking
about how mexicans didn't
look like they they we walked like we
didn't have feet we walked like we had
wheels like
and just kind of just roll around and
stuff right like like they look you
can't see their feet because of the
pants that they wear and they look like
they
they roll on wheels they don't have feet
this dude was like two people
uh i was two people after
and i went up there and i said hey that
guy said that mexicans don't have any
feed i said well he knows because i put
this one in his ass
i was probably been doing it like three
times
oh yeah and everybody went crazy because
it was like from the guy from two
and he was so much so much of his act
that when i did it that was a lesson i
learned early like i could i could do
that
to somebody in front of me but i learned
that i didn't ask hey do you guys ever
go up there and like talk about that i
just did it
and that was you know that was a jumping
off point from then that you know you
could hear something and make a joke
on the at that at that point yeah
yeah
that was crazy but but the show i don't
think that if if you know 20 years ago
when the show started if i wasn't
the creator or the person that says hey
we should do a story about my dad and we
should just talk about about this
that if i didn't have that option i
don't think i would have gotten hired as
an actor
yeah like i had to come with something
complete already
that
could have worked but the odds of it not
working were probably high yeah i didn't
think about that but if you were to just
hire us as actors that whole family we
would we'd have never
got got put together because you had to
have
somebody write that write that show or
keep the whole that mantle you know yeah
that's that's kind of what it's like to
be me you know like as an independent
like i had to go independent like
because i was at a major label and for
like
like sometimes people like oh you went
to a major level you know you tried to
do that route but it's like
understanding us as a community
when i was selling my cds on the street
nobody believed in me nobody thought i
was going to make it you know a lot of
times our own people would be like oh
well you know whatever i grew up with
her like
[__] the whole time the whole time yeah
like oh i grew up where she ain't going
to be [__] whatever nobody cares you
need that cosign you need whether that's
you know that that out of our ethnicity
cosine for somebody to finally be like
oh [__] that person's [__] with this
person they must and that's when they
kind of follow suit so my going to a
major label was to finally
you know let my peers know like yo i
might have a shot and so i went that
route but they didn't understand me you
know when i was in their office and they
said the taco circuit you know they
mentioned the chitlin circuit and the
taco circuit and this is a major label
you know and you're just sitting there
like holy [__] i can't believe this is
being i know you know what i mean
and so and and you're like okay bet like
i'm learning this is my first time i
come from two parents from mexico they
were immigrants that you know i don't
have any family that even went to high
school here like i don't know [__] so
i'm finally in a major label in new york
this is a big time and i'm like not
going to be like [__] you you know
whatever so i'm like let me get in here
and let me see what's up but what i did
was separate my business and i go so
this right here y'all can't touch like
which is handled by my cousin my brother
like we're going to make generational
wealth here and one will give you this
know the product the product which was
always going to be a product that never
was very personal to me it was the
rapper but anyway so i go in there
whatever but then i start to realize
they don't understand the identity you
don't you don't get what i am you know
like for example you want me to make
reggaeton well i'm mexican so it's kind
of hard to explain to you that there's
like puerto ricans and colombians and
mexicans and all these other people and
then you gotta kind of like explain so
you're teaching
and they didn't really ever understand
the whole thing until i was like okay
you know what this isn't gonna work love
y'all thanks for the check or whatever
but i gotta go um feed my family and
then now as an independent person i
could be like here's my identity here's
the lane we're going to build and it's
going to take forever and i'm not going
to get as famous as maybe somebody on a
major label but at least we're going to
build a real way and now
that same label i've found people that
are you know like maybe uh they're being
chased down by that label and they'll be
like oh you know that artists know the
product we need you to be like her and
i'm like i was on your label like i now
have become the blueprint for what some
people can show like i'm going to make a
new snow the product but better because
i'm going to finance it and it's like
snow product went through a lot of
struggle like to get to where you know i
can now be an example and that's awesome
like to me that was success like i did
it i did what i needed to do was be some
sort of representation and get to a
certain level where i could prove that i
am a
a proven product and a proven concept
and now because if you get signed by a
major label they're not signing anybody
especially now like you have to actually
have something that they consider
commercially marketable like you know if
you want to be an artist an artist i
mean prince you know
um
wrote slave on his face and he realized
that he didn't have control of his own
music
and he got it back he got it back at the
end yeah but
you know he left and then the eagles i
think put their album out themselves and
they put it in at walmart's in the
walmart it didn't come out like that but
you know before it was all about a major
label
but yet they owned you
and then recently in the last 20 years
it became about the 360 deal
which the 360 deal would be like for me
or else they would be like they take
your touring they take your acting they
take your publishing they take your
merch merch they take
or if you're a patreon
anything you sell beer they take all of
that on the 360.
and then you would think like [__] who
would say who would sign that deal they
sign they sell them all the time yeah
they sign them all the time and they own
all of your [__] man you make a dollar
they make money yeah and before like she
said to separate like this stuff like
you can have this
there's no the product you can have that
i'll give you that yeah but you can't
have this this is like my family and we
do this all together yeah and and you
know it was a lifesaver
completely because then you'll be
working for them like people that are
out there and they tour and they owe
money because they're in deficit you
know because
if they give you an advance of a million
dollars you're like hey man we got a
million dollar advance you have to pay
it back yeah they don't realize you have
to pay it back and the interest rates
are terrible
[Music]
business loan bro like what the hell wow
yeah no it's terrible and then there's
and you know why and sometimes you know
culturally there's also that where it's
like your primos are like well you're
not as famous as so and so and it's like
now you have to break it down and be
like well this is why because i don't
want to do that marketing and blah blah
and all this stuff and it's like it's
hard to explain like that
we in our community need ownership and
we need to build these new ways and
eventually i would say you know 10 years
from now maybe like there will be these
you know like production houses and like
all these things we're gonna have
equity in
in this industry but it was very it's
been very hard to be able to even get
there and to to claim our space because
a lot of times everybody loves the
aesthetic you know if you think latino
they're like oh let's do low riders and
[__] you know bald guys that are
going to be in this thing and it's like
well yeah but that was
that was that was a puerto rican song
and now that got taken up you know but
then when a mexican rapper comes through
and does it we have color lines and you
know stereotypes and pigeonholing and we
have all these things
it's a whole thing oh no that's right
that's right that's right i hosted the
latin grammys in miami
and when uh i think things that north
dakota won nobody clapped
[__] [__] so i went up there i
was hosting i said you know how does a
band win uh latin grammy and nobody in
this place clapped
yeah and you could hear them
yeah they like you because you can see
it yeah you can see the bias
towards the latinos on this side yeah if
you weren't from new york you weren't
uh you know yeah that they gave you
they treated you like you were like you
[__] didn't belong there yeah crazy i
was nominated for one and those don't
get televised you know like those are
the type of things where you're just
like and it sucks because when you speak
up on these type of things you look like
you're complaining or you're salty or
whatever and it's like well how how else
are you supposed to speak up because
when we don't speak up on certain issues
we get looked at as you're not
representing right or you're not this
you're not that but then when you do you
look salty and it's it's a very
tough
dynamic also let's say let's say uh
the quarterback of the rams
all right whatever his name is
but uh
like that guy being a caucasian you know
that guy was picked number one he was at
the light was with the lions didn't play
very well but it was pretty good got
beat up got hurt came back
like you wouldn't expect grant
like him to represent
the white people like that quarterback
like they go that guy's playing for all
of us
right but when you're black or you're
latino like
you don't get that
that thing where you're just playing for
yourself yeah like you you shouldn't
have to we shouldn't have to carry the
banner for all of the other people that
want to make something of themselves and
if they don't they think that it's
impossible it's not impossible but if if
you don't not everybody does like yeah
nobody does right nobody becomes a
detective and goes to the police
campaign so much hard work that's even
if you wanted to
open a shop where you had coffee and you
t in your in your neighborhood
and that place opens and that guy do
they always put the first dollar on the
wall it's important how hard it is to
open a business or run any type of
business and then you have people around
you saying oh man this [__] that ain't
you ain't [__] that ain't [__] you're
never gonna be i mean but nobody else
gets it yeah that matthew stafford's not
getting into it dude you're awful yeah i
don't even know what you're doing over
there
but us how dare you walk around being
white and you're not representing if you
succeed they hate you if you fail
they love you
look at your
your everybody loves underdog the thing
is that we were taught to be humble
right like we have to be so humble that
we're walking around like like if we
don't do that like or if if you don't
you go you know like you you you kind of
are more boisterous about the way like
what you're doing they're like oh you
better calm down you better chill don't
forget where you came from and it's like
i don't forget where i came from i think
about that [__] all the time it's the
reason that some friendships have ended
because i got certain traumas that make
me you know i don't trust certain people
or like i i get offended because people
say things or you know what i mean like
the whole like must be nice we all don't
we're not so lucky and you're like i
didn't sleep for [__] ten years
you know what i mean like so those
things this is the way my grandma this
is where my grandmother was let's say
that i was in in china
and i started to dig a hole from china
remember they would say talk about
digging to china oh yeah let's say that
i started this is the way this i'm going
to describe my grandmother
and what she was like in one sentence
let's say i was in china
and i decided i was going to dig my way
back to the united states
so i started china and i start digging
through the earth
takes me
10 years
i dig
i i'm in my neighborhood i'm in front of
my house i've dug from china
up to mission hills
i get out i put the shovel down there i
wipe my bra i sit down my grandma would
come out and go it must be nice
if i'm just
sitting around doing nothing
i just [__] i just dug my hair for
[__] china i didn't see none of that
i see you just laying there with a
shovel right there yeah
they they just cannot say
congratulations i think you're you know
so difficult to do your coach
flores from the raiders yeah how long
did it take him
to get nominated
because hall of famer
it's true
got no credit for him
should be in the hall of fame yeah so he
here here's the bias let me just say
whatever
this the buffalo bills in the 90s lost
four super bowls
the coach and the the quarterback and
they are both in the hall of fame
tom flores and and and jim plunkett won
two super bowls each and they're out so
four losses mean more than two wins yeah
i mean it's yeah that's crazy yeah it's
sad about that tom flores don't let us
work there but that won't let us be like
yeah but that's you know that's what it
is yeah and it you know and even in
nowadays right like with social media
let's say instagram like
you know i'm sitting there and i'm
posting about immigrants rights and i'm
posting about the elotero getting beat
up and i'm posting about all these
things and you know what happens to me
i get
shadow band i get less engagement i get
all that like they they punish you for
those things and that's where people
don't understand because it's like yo
i'm trying to build
a platform so that i can speak on these
things but every single time that i
speak on it through those type of things
i get shadow bands so now my platform
isn't going to grow so now where is the
voice because people aren't going to be
happy until i speak on every single
issue and that's going to shadow ban me
more and more and more that's right and
then they go where'd you go you know
they're not going to realize why all
that type of stuff happened so sometimes
it's better to not necessarily say it on
social media that's right help out the
causes do the things quietly move move a
certain way because the way that it
works the way the algorithm works
unfortunately it [__] us up but you
know so they're not going to see that
they're not
so that too because of the way that you
want to talk about this how your people
have set this note so
let's talk about you
how people how people start to get paid
right how people start to get paid but
also
playing more toward the middle versus
playing
hard right or hard left so you play you
sound like you play in the middle and
you survive forever
but the minute you take on issues that
even involve the people that are
listening to you and follow you they
don't want that [__] they don't
i just want to hear whatever don't talk
because they're going to disagree and
nobody can agree to disagree anymore
yeah
i've had 10 years like i've had a decade
right over a decade of doing the same
thing i was talking on breakfast club
charlemagne sway i was speaking on these
issues so [__] long ago that at this
point i'm [__] exhausted i've said
the same [__] forever
but now it's like oh if you don't speak
on this you must not and it's like are
you [__] kidding me i walked into
rooms i don't give a [__] of you if you
sit there in a room full of chicanos and
you say the the the [__] you're supposed
to say they already heard it we already
lived it i walked into rooms where that
[__] wasn't even gonna be brought up as
a matter of fact they probably looked at
me like what the [__] is this girl
talking about but i did it because
that's where you need to speak up that's
where you need to [__] do it but
unfortunately sometimes your own will
have that crabs in a bucket mentality
where it's like you know when i was at
abc the president of abc invited me to a
marketing creative
thing where there were representatives
from all the car companies
walmart and restaurants and we're in
this i still remember i said he sat at
the head that i said over here my show
was on and everybody sat there
and the guy stood up and he said to me
how do we sell hondas
to mexicans
and i said
what
so i told them put la honda
but you know what i told them is you
don't sell hondas to mexicans you sell
hondas to people
yeah
and if the people like your product they
buy it not mexican people i mean what
the i mean seriously this is
[__] today even today like how do you
how do we sell
electric there's another one ready for
this one how do we get hey george how do
we get more latinos vaccinated
add salt
[Laughter]
the only thing is yeah tell them
tell them they don't want you to i mean
you know it's like but but they should
just to everybody if your product's good
it's good for whoever it's not just good
you know i mean
that's how we get
but you know what you know what and i
get it and i respect it and i am like
that however here's what i learned in
the last couple years of dealing with
these people couple years ago
these are these [__] these couples
okay
sometimes we
hold our ground and we have the balls to
say it and we go in those rooms and we
go you know what no you don't want to be
stereotypical whatever but here comes
[__] your cousin joe that never lived
the [__] life and then he's gonna
come in and be the token
mexican and he's gonna be like oh i'll
[__] do the dance and unfortunately
then those people were like you know
what we don't like you person that keeps
saying no we like this guy because this
guy plays ball and now you get those
corny ass weird ass shows commercial
scripts whatever and then they don't
work and then when they don't work they
go oh you know what well we tried a
latin show last last year or last
quarter and it didn't work so you know
we're going to focus our energy here and
unfortunately it's like well you went
the easy route with the least resistance
because you didn't want to have the
conversation about what it what really
matters you'd rather go with this
[__] mike primo who nobody even likes
in the family now you're making a show
based on that [__] and it's not
connecting because nobody likes that
right i don't think those things ever
ever work
so i think for us we somehow we feel
like
what we do i mean if you're not creating
your own
content we're not creating our own
content nobody's going to create it for
us because we don't know another writer
that wrote on cheers i met with him he
was a paramount and he came back and
they said well i said what you what they
say he goes
he said he doesn't know how to write for
a latino i was like [__] just
write to write like
so that's what they think like they
think that they couldn't write a
situation but in the show that we were
doing i told them let's just write
good stories forget about what the color
the people are you write good stories
don't write a latino story but you can
do those stories i threw away my wife's
little wooden box that had the stuff
from her grandmother we were moving and
i threw all the change in the jar and i
saw this little wooden thing and i threw
it in the jar i just didn't and she
comes over and she goes where's all the
stuff that was in here and i said oh
it's in the and dude this was like this
is all i have for my my mama's mom
oh shoot and i was like
what did i do i made a show about it
my wife says to me i feel like she died
all over again
i was like what the [__] does that mean
like she died again and on the show i
had constance say it's like she died all
over again had her say the same line
that my wife said damn
but that's why but that's why those
shows survive because you're
they're about an emotion like if you sit
in a room you know they sit in a room
and people come up with things to write
they're not going to write they're not
going to write that they're not going to
you have to recreate the things that
happen
in vietnam and in war they create the
[__] right you see them
saving private ryan or the platoon or
apocalypse now like
to the to the t of that's where that's
what it looked like to be there there's
no way that you can talk about
the history and and
if you're honest with it have it not
connect because you know we're all going
to suffer loss you remember this person
remember that person and the more real
you make it the more real
people are drawn to what's real and and
that's [__] yeah when somebody a
rapper gets found out to you know claim
to be from the hood but they're i mean i
don't i don't think drake
is from where he says but but it doesn't
mean that he's he's not incredible but
yeah you know some guys are all about
that i learned from this show you know
where you started from what you were
doing brought up constantly
i was shocked to find out
yeah we're gonna go almost done she did
her i'm sorry what yeah
oh
who's gym man
you guys gotta go we got five minutes
wait who gotta go you guys gotta go
i don't know oh i thought oh oh
i'm like it's barely getting good oh
wait my brother's here
oh yes
first of all he's a big fan
she started out you know you start out
making your own cds and push them like
this
she started out she used to dance and
put her hat out there to collect money
down on the beach
that's that's what she did that's how
she started out and eventually got
through it went through acting school
and
look at her now that's awesome let me
tell you that [__] is hard man i
couldn't
i couldn't go out there there was a
comedian that worked on the beach i
couldn't have done that [__] i do you
should go out there and work on the
beach with people that you know the guy
mike collier might call you and you know
what i've seen him on a beach couldn't
imagine doing that like going out there
and going hey i'm gonna tell some jokes
yeah i got told about a show we were
gonna do like some show like so many
[__] years ago it was crazy but yeah
um
yeah i mean getting out there and
[__] being on the street my caller
used to wear that five years old
yeah i was five years old and my family
would make me sing you know mariachi
songs at the bar you know like i got on
top of the pool table and saying
you know like anything
you know whatever to to kind of and they
would give me money unfortunately now i
realize that my mom would just keep the
money
um like i'll keep it for you and then
yeah unfortunately is my brother here oh
my gosh you know so that's my brother
like that's the
my brother and i um do everything from
editing to vlogs music to tour managing
to [__] filming to my music videos
like every single thing about my life
it's been
us kind of having each other's back and
being like bro we don't got our parents
here so let's [__] yeah that's
awesome you've done good still yeah
thank you you've done good now we found
out we have three new siblings in mexico
but you know that's mexican dads as well
because some so truly some mexicans it's
funny man because you know somebody told
me that we were golfing that that when
his dad died
that they found out he had a whole other
family
right
so
i go how did you find out and he goes
they sent us some pictures
and we're looking at the pictures pero
stan como in in in in the
my riviera tane cancun
and they're like
and the dude's there and his arms around
his family and the kids and i go what
did you what did your mom do like she
started crying and i said you're [__]
of course and i go was she crying
because she goes no he's crying because
he never [__] took us over there
so she so so my dad would always tell
the the family his family
that he was tired
that he was you know uh diabetic
that he didn't have the energy to do it
and he didn't really want to go anywhere
he didn't want to travel he didn't want
to do anything as a family he was always
tired and he was always saying his legs
hurt you know
so then so then they find these pictures
and he's wearing shorts he's on the
beach every part that he said he had
wrong with them is fixed in the picture
and and and he said you know my dad just
didn't want to do that [__] with us yeah
and that's what it was and that's [__]
up that's when i started committing
crimes bro when i started [__]
robbing and doing all that [__] i found
a picture of my dad and his new they
never claimed themselves but whatever
family on vacation in [__] mexico
they had a whole yes or no and you were
there [__]
i'm talking about 50 people family
reunion and i wasn't invited in mexico
and i was like you
and now so yeah yeah don't deny it now
[__] for the record there's
nothing
how come they didn't invite you i don't
[__] know my dad's an [__] he's
got joy
he didn't have a second family he just
didn't have much into no he just brought
his new
family
to mexico and everybody was there and
they were just you know like family
reunion and i was just like i remember
seeing the picture and be like yeah
would you look oh yeah
you're the only one that wasn't there
straight up but it's cuz yeah i mean
it's because i told it like it is i've
always had a mouth on me so like you
know like i would be like yo what's up
cause
shorty the girl he was with was like my
my mom's best friend and so i had you
know i'm the only one that can see it my
brother was more quiet he was just like
i don't know what's going on are y'all
feeding me but me i was like what's up
with this lady yeah so that's how it
happened my brother's like yo there but
did you know what you were walking into
a second ago right yeah
he's seeing the beers my brother's right
now oh [__] my sister's doing it grab
one of those
hey but you know what it's true man i
why did the whole set is that how did
that start like guys
and guys today
you know a couple another guy that found
out that he had a second family
and kids that lived within a mile of
where they lived
so the dude was like he was doing two
families and they were they lived like
right there
officially on record i only got one
family that's it you don't have a family
in vietnam we'll talk about it
but you were like you were like
progressive though because you know like
accepting your son like you were you
went in the military like you were
progressive like you know our like some
of our fathers were they were just so
like [__] macho and all that like
you know like all that [__] it's like it
was very
they were talking
how did they decide to get does that
second family know about that family or
do they keep them both separate like
my dad's new wife is one year younger
than me
wow i'm not laughing at that i'm not
laughing at you
i'm laughing guys me
my brother's like get my sister off the
show did she tell you to call her mom no
you can't call her mom no actually you
know why she's in the red man i'm
telling you i hadn't seen i hadn't seen
my family for a long time or my dad
decided or whatever and i went to mexico
ready to not like her i actually like
her she's she's very good and like you
know she's a hard worker
it's like your little sister and your
mom it's like you know i'm not gonna
ever see her again
not gonna ever see any of them again but
you know it was it was nice it was like
oh okay cool you're alive great i know
man that's wow you know toxicity bro it
runs deep you know uh i was uh you know
i'm an older gentleman and uh i used to
go on with some girls that were younger
okay and then explained that to his joy
and then one time one time we're flying
to san francisco
and
we're sitting in the front and one of
the last guy gets on he's got cool pants
he's older he's got cool shoes cool hair
he's got cool sunglasses and then his
girl gets on she's like half his age
or or more
and you can see that they look like he's
trying to dress like he's trying to be
young like a chrome hearts t-shirt and
his hair's up like you know
like mine
everybody's glasses
get it now and then the girl gets on
and she is hot but younger and then they
sit there and they're like making out
during the flight and i look over and
i'm like man i told the dude that was
with me i said hey man is that the way
that i look and he goes no
and since that time
i don't i don't
i don't stop dating girls
no no
yeah yeah i don't want anybody to see me
with any girls but
uh
just that was that wide like that that
did it because it's almost like the lord
said i'ma put somebody in front of you
yeah i'm up i'm gonna hold a mirror up
to you and see if you see anything wrong
with it yeah and the minute they got on
i looked over was like oh man that's
that's not a good thing that's got you i
feel that yeah hey man somebody said how
come you don't date people your own age
and i said have you seen people my age
i mean
you can't be in bed barefooted
somebody's missing it
what's up critics what can i say it's
like money
you have the line for the compression
sock
[Laughter]
right if you're trying to be romantic
man bad feet will take action all the
[__] romance i don't know it is and
then you can ask you can ask my dear
wife i'm a foot man
yeah and they're all doodles and [__]
man
oh shoot this podcast taking turns no i
mean i'm loving it i'm trying to make
sure that that wasn't my brother telling
me like get the [__] off
no that's not you all right good
he's got the the baby total have a nail
but it's painted
because from far away they put a little
dash right there they pretend that
nail's there ah
yeah yeah you know like sometimes
football players have white that they
mark up the put tape over the logo they
have to draw or they used to get
stickers logo and put them on there
because they had to show their logo yeah
you know he's a raider man
yeah we out here yeah we're i think
we're talking to a new coach not the guy
that
a real coach
not our coach with special teams
because i said hey how does i do my
friends or you know jim gray i said how
does thing go how's our coach doing he
goes well he's a special teams coach
that moved up to being a head coach and
i'm like i think we need a real
coach that's a head coach i heard he
wrote every player a letter before their
final game every player a handwritten
letter
oh what'd it say
i mean thanks like it was for giving a
special teams guy a chance more or less
that's nice
i mean the game
yeah we're here what are you expecting
that super bowl show with those guys uh
the rap show
who's playing again who's that
it's everyone snoop dre
eminem okay kendrick
and mary j blige yeah okay
why is an ice cube there i think a lot i
i expect to feel
how old i was when all of them were
on you know
on trl
no i would it's hard to meet him yeah
that's
that would be crazy that would be as
crazy
that was that'd be
i was telling you that's like
i've never met any of them
i tried to meet him we did the thing for
the veterans in dc at the national mall
and i was trying to get to meet him and
it was i couldn't meet him i i've never
met any of them but i've heard what
snoop dogg
is really a good guy good guy and very
good businessman
yeah i mean
allegedly smokes 81 joints a day
bro i [__] i [__] left shooting a
music video with him i go home i'm
listening to him on the radio and then i
went home and i was watching tv and he
was on tv like on a commercial i was
like yo stoop is always constantly doing
[__] that's
that's like the level of like that's
what you want to reach it's like you're
never too you're never too big like
you're not corny like you're always just
you're gonna be around you did it you
know what i mean like that's that's a
legend he did some movies he acted a
little bit but then also he's got his
products come out
and they're good you know
everything
yeah corona commercials
together like i'm talking about all
kinds of stuff that's awesome you know
just visibility being here that's it
yeah and that's from a person smoking
weed as much as everybody liked to tell
us we were going to be lazy you know
smoking weed or whatever even though i
only smoked asleep now but you know but
you know what i i don't really smoke but
i would get lazy when when uh
when i was younger
i was going to some party with you know
all these girls were going to be in the
cme valley so back then you had to take
like san fernando uh rinaldi or support
you know to get over there whatever
street and as we were smoking in the car
about almost when we got there i got sad
i told the dude let's go
look at that small smoky weed i was
driving i got sad out of the way you are
sad for me i got so sad from smoking and
i said hey man i just wanted to go home
we turned around and went back
why'd you get sad i don't know
i know a good friend of mine
might even say something like
that
but but i did i was as i was driving
like that's one too many jokes as i was
driving i got i got sad man
why when i was when i before i got high
i was all happy it's probably going to
be great
what sign are you like i'm going to die
is that why i got that okay now what
sign are you you asked me earlier what
sign are you doing my son's a taurus uh
cancer cancer no i'm a yorona that's why
i was just happy i'm not straight up
i almost cried two times during this
podcast
he started crying give me give me a
shout at the giggle and i'll dance with
you
oh [__]
don't try to tell you the answer
if
anybody's following though
here's the latest on her oh originally
she killed her kids and every night she
cries yeah but she got remarried and the
kids now that she has they all get along
well
they're all in good school she had a
secret family the whole time
drown those
here's a difference too like you know a
lot of us moms were single parents and
they meet a guy and the guy doesn't like
that that the kid they don't kill the
kid they make them hide
in the other room until until they're in
love then they go come on mikko yeah but
you know they go
they would say go in there and hide i
don't want anybody to know i have a kid
yet play video games yeah you know do
something
damn and then
i can tell you something before we go
forward what's that i have a kid oh uh
is that all right
no i mean we're in love with the kids
right but they hired them in the
beginning that's hilarious at least
that's where i came from you
they would say hi
yeah
they go to the park and the guy's there
george you hide you dug down under the
field
[Laughter]
all right this was fun huh yeah this is
great
shout out anything you're doing tell the
people where to follow subscribe
anything like that um yeah i mean
everyday days uh on youtube that's my
podcast it's know the product i'm a
rapper um look me up wherever she's a
great rapper do you like it yes yes
i said i can understand i can't talk
that fast but but also in the in the
flow and the flow's good but the but the
lyrics and what you're about is
thank you it's great yeah i'm very i'm
very i'm very proud of you i've been a
fan ever since the tech nine verse uh
yeah i was looking it up that was almost
like 10 years ago now yeah
that was exciting yeah yeah just
consider myself lucky i got to meet you
and listen here and talk to you in
conversation no whenever man i'm 10
minutes away like anybody anybody that's
about something that's real comes from a
place that's
has not been the easiest thank you
sometimes people you know you know if we
had our choices would we want things
handed to us i think
superficially yes but then if you get
[__] handed to you you don't work as
hard for the things that you want
because exactly there's that there
like the raiders they can't get in this
end zone they bring out the kicker the
deuce never missed in his career
so what what's the what's the hurry of
trying to get to the end zone right and
then the dude
he hasn't missed ever yeah
i mean so instead of like working on the
red zone thing they just kick a field
goal and they move on and then we you
know we end up losing like
this is the most depressing motivational
speech i've ever
no yeah i'm much like the raiders you
know i've been i've won i've lost a lot
and i will win again is what's really
going to happen you know i think well
you already got a show yeah
you know perfect perfect for that show
yeah i mean you know i got a job yeah i
got a job today yeah we're gonna we're
gonna work together perfect i already
got the party and everything
i've never been to perfect before other
than by my girlfriend so we're here
we're perfect for a job perfect i gotta
in that show in that show my my daughter
runs a a club in uh like hacienda
heights but it's not it's a gentleman's
school but but they dress in like day of
the dead
okay you know stuff in the you know so
the manager there
the girl there yeah i'm a dancer at the
club oh okay all right
he's in his mind his name is uh al
bondigus
all right everybody
yeah thank you so much
you